أنا من الجيل الذي ولد مع
النكبة بمجازرها وخيامها
ومصاعبها، لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأرى
ذلك يتكرر في حياتي. 70٪ من
الفلسطينيين في غزة هم بالفعل
لاجئون، وقد حرموا من حقهم في
العودة لعقود من الزمن، والعديد منهم الآن  لقد
دمرت منازلهم في غزة
في هجمات سابقة
الفلسطينيون في غزة اليوم
ينعون أحبائهم ويحزنون على
منازلهم التي بنوها وأعادوا بنائها لأنفسهم
ولعائلاتهم إنهم يبكون
مدينتهم إنهم يبكون قطاع غزة كما هو الحال مع جميع
معالمه الأرضية  تم تدمير كل مكان
كان للناس فيه ذكريات سعيدة، والآن
امتلأت كل زاوية بالعذاب والموت
والمعاناة خلال 100 يوم. لقد
نزح كل فلسطيني في غزة تقريبًا عدة مرات من منزل
إليك إلى مأوى للأمم المتحدة إلى
خيمة بحثًا عن الأمان
في كل مكان.  العثور على الأمان في
أي مكان البحث عن الحياة في أي
مكان يقابله الموت في
كل مكان لقد دمرت إسرائيل عمدا
كل ما قتلته وألحقت الضرر
بأطفالنا أطبائنا صحفيينا
مهندسينا شعرائنا
أكاديميينا لقد دمرت
متطلبات الحياة ذاتها والحياة في
غزة، لا يوجد منازل للعيش فيها  لا مدارس ولا
جامعات للدراسة لا مستشفيات
للشفاء لا مساجد ولا كنائس للعبادة لا
أرض زراعية للزراعة لا مخابز للخبز
لا مياه صالحة للشرب لا أسواق
للشراء
من لا أمان لا
مستقبل